mais je pense que
vous savez j'avais à mes prédécesseurs
qui disait edgar pisani que j'admire
beaucoup qui disait le drame en
politique c'est de sombrer dans le
détail id oublier l'essentiel et je
pense qu'une politique vision politique
qui repose sur ici la suppression des
sapins ou la la suppression du foie
parfois l'arrêt du tour de france est un
très bon exemple de ce que edgar pisani
voulait dire on sombre dans le détail ce
n'est pas une vision politique que de
dire moi mon projet de supprimer de foie
gras moi mon projet situe primes et des
satins qui prisaient
personnellement comme beaucoup de
français
j'ai la chance d'avoir un sapin chez moi
et je suis très content de pouvoir en
profiter avec mes quatre enfants et je
compte bien manger du foie gras à noël
être est
ce que le foie gras est une partie de
notre identité oui oui et est-ce qu'on
peut être
des territoires mais où est-ce qu'ils
s'arrêtent le bien-être animal vous
savez quand vous allez dans un bois vous
avez vous allez c'est quoi l'étape
d'après vous allez dans un abattoir on
va dire et c'est d'ailleurs très
intéressant votre question parce que je
vais vous faire un scoop pour manger de
la viande faut tuer un animal
ça fait la fin de l'animal elle est
potentiellement assez tragique et vous
voyez le débat qu'on a aujourd'hui dans
la société même si le débat le débat sur
le gavage des oies pas sur le dos ce que
je veux dire par là c'est que
aujourd'hui on tourne dans une société
où au titre du bien-être animal ou
d'autres on va en arriver à se dire eh
bien demain on arrête le foie gras et
puis l'étape d'après ces on va arrêter
de tuer des animaux
[Musique]